[Musica]
politiche ed estetica dove estetica va
tradotta con il termine Greco aesthesis
Che significa sensazione percezione nel
mio intervento presento quello che la
mia ricerca considera uno dei rapporti
fondamentali di potere del nostro tempo
il rapporto tra le immagini e la
politica sullo schermo
vi dico brevemente l'obiettivo generale
della mia ricerca che è quella di
definire le basi teoriche
da cui sviluppare una sorta di
rivoluzione pedagogica che inserisca
come materia fondamentali nei nostri
sistemi educativi il linguaggio e le
tecniche audiovisive
quello che sostengo è che non è più
razionalmente accettabile che in un
immaginario politico sociale culturale
che è costituito da immagini televisive
cinematografiche e ovviamente delle
immagini sui social le persone non siano
formate a leggere e a scrivere con
questo linguaggio
Allora da questa prospettiva
i miei punti di partenza sono tre
la teoria politica deve accettare che
viviamo in una società delle immagini
dobbiamo essere consapevoli che la
nostra percezione della realtà è
determinata da quello che chiamo il
campo del visibile e il campo del non
visibile e che questi campi come
spiegherò Fra poco sono completamente
prodotti dal linguaggio
ideologico delle immagini sullo schermo
e che quindi lo schermo qualsiasi
schermo dal nostro PC alla TV allo
smartphone allo schermo allo schermo del
cinema e dunque sempre politico perché è
sempre formativo
e faccio due premesse metodologiche al
lavoro le immagini sono ideologiche
perché esprimono sempre
un'intenzione che è a Monte
dell'immagine stessa
Dunque sono sempre più o meno
ideologiche queste immagini popolano la
nostra mente e popolano la nostra mente
quando pensiamo
prenderci il tempo per pensarle Questa è
l'epoque fenomenologica cioè sospendere
il giudizio su queste immagini che
popolano la nostra mente ci aiuta a
tornare alle cose stesse e a provare a
ricercare nuove immagini per esprimere
meglio la realtà in questo caso in
questo nostro caso oggi la realtà della
montagna
una seconda Premessa una parte del mio
discorso e del contributo si riferisce
ad alcuni spunti che derivano da un
lavoro che sto facendo sulla semiotica
del cinema di Pasolini
Voglio inserire infine queste
considerazioni sul tema di oggi cioè la
montagna tra passato e futuro
dobbiamo prenderci il tempo per pensare
a come utilizziamo e a Come pensiamo la
vita della montagna dobbiamo prenderci
il tempo di pensare
alle immagini che dentro di noi abbiamo
della montagna perché forse possiamo
scoprire Ecco il fine del mio discorso
che anche della montagna C'è un campo
del visibile e un campo del non visibile
che passa ideologicamente sullo schermo
e che ci forza a pensare in un modo o in
un altro
brevissimamente dividerò il mio
intervento in quattro parti
In primo luogo introduco brevemente Che
cos'è che cosa intendo per campo del
visibile campo nel non visibile In
secondo luogo identifico la differenza
tra estetica e politica nella differenza
tra immagine simbolica e immagini
Iconica in terzo luogo tramite Pasolini
definisco un concetto che per me è
fondamentale che è il concetto di segno
iconico di se stesso e in quarto luogo
spiego come la connessione diretta tra
estetica e politica possa aiutarci a
pensare il campo del non visibile Infine
mi permetto di definire tre di suggerire
tre modi per pensare la montagna quando
immaginiamo la montagna Allora prima
parte che cos'è la società dell'immagine
la società dell'immagine è il sistema in
cui viviamo ed è un sistema politico
economico in cui le forze produttive
di tecnologie odio visive come la
televisione il cinema il marketing i
social media i giornali come il
precedente relatore ci mostrava sono
alleate per creare ricreare
continuamente una certa percezione della
realtà questa percezione della realtà
passa principalmente attraverso lo
schermo e quindi lo schermo è il campo
del visibile e sullo schermo
ciò che si vede esiste ciò che non si
vede non esiste
quindi noi siamo formati a pensare
questo che ciò che si vede sullo schermo
esiste è reale c'è ciò che non si vede
non esiste non è reale non c'è
E qual è il problema evidentemente
che ciò che non esiste sullo schermo ma
è reale è il non visibile
faccio due esempi di cronaca ma senza
entrare ovviamente in polemiche ma che
secondo me sono interessanti
nel campo del visibile ad esempio Noi
siamo stati martellati per due anni
dalla polarizzazione tra
chi era provacino e chi era contrario al
vaccino
Tuttavia nessuno ha posto una questione
che non è visibile Ma che è
importantissima mio giudizio che nel
2022 con gli astronauti ormai che vanno
su Marte con la biogenetica che può
modificare gli organismi con le
automobili che sfrecciano a 200 all'ora
autocomandate
una parte piuttosto numerosa degli
italiani è scettica rispetto al sapere
scientifico Noi abbiamo un sapere
scientifico che non viene valorizzato
dalla nostra cultura
un sapere tecnologico che non viene
valorizzato dalla nostra cultura e
questo non viene visto e ovviamente non
vengono viste posizioni che rasentano
Permettetemi Il medioevo da certi punti
di vista seconda questione per mostrarvi
come funziona il campo del visibile il
campo del non visibile la crisi
energetica legata all'attuale guerra in
Ucraina Pro Domo nostra stiamo rendendo
visibile
l'urgenza di
rigassificatori di centrali nucleari di
nuovi scenari di sfruttamento energetico
del territorio
ma contemporaneamente cade nel non
visibile quello che un anno fa era
visibilissimo che è sostanzialmente
l'importanza della transizione ecologica
delle energie alternative e così via
Dunque
concludo questa prima parte cosa c'entra
questo con la montagna direi
semplicemente che anche rispetto alla
montagna abbiamo un campo del visibile e
del non visibile e che pensando alla
montagna trapassato e futuro dobbiamo
anche noi fare i conti con le immagini e
dunque i pensieri che popolano il nostro
campo del visibile
per spiegare questo passo alla seconda
parte allora ci sono tre questioni
semiotiche che vorrei in qualche modo
proporvi quali immagini abbiamo a
disposizione per pensare
quali immagini possono mostrarci il
campo del non visibile e quali immagini
possono irrompere nel campo del visibile
per mostrarci altro per rispondere a
questo vorrei presentarvi la distinzione
tra segno simbolico tra immagini
simbolica e immagini Iconica un'immagine
o un segno simbolico è segno di un altro
segno cioè una convenzione arbitraria
molto utile nella comunicazione e noi
viviamo nella comunicazione visto che
viviamo nella società dell'immagine ed è
utilissima ovviamente all'immaginazione
del desiderio
per fare alcuni esempi semplicissimi la
parola montagna è una è un simbolo che
serve per esprimere la montagna il
cartello comunità montana è un cartello
che Rinvia ad un posto che è la montagna
il cartellone pubblicitario di una
stazione Montana è un simbolo che rinvia
a qualcos'altro venite qui a fare le
ferie la pubblicità il cinema la
televisione ovviamente i social media
sono strutture simboliche un po' più
raffinate
Se ad esempio vediamo una pubblicità di
Cortina o un film su Cortina o un
documentario sulle cime di Cortina o
facciamo un Esercizio mentale come ci
proponeva un relatore precedentemente
Su che cosa immaginiamo di Cortina o
ancora se Marco Il mio amico mi posta su
Instagram le sue vacanze a Cortina che
cosa vediamo vediamo sicuramente a piste
innevate se siamo in inverno se vediamo
il bella gente che prende il sole che si
diverte nei rifugi a 2000 metri cioè
vediamo simboli
che non ci offrono la pensione diretta
di Che cos'è la montagna ma rinviano ad
altro rinviano al divertimento
rinviano alla possibilità di divertirsi
perché sia soldi
di alla posizione sociale che uno ha
perché va a Cortina cioè rinviano a
qualcos'altro una parola ma a me
verrebbe da dire la parola più semplice
rinviano Al desiderio
un segno iconico invece un'immagine
Iconica comporta invece un grado di
realismo perché in un certo senso ha le
stesse proprietà dell'oggetto reale non
solo in termini di proporzioni relazioni
e somiglianze ma soprattutto in termini
di percezione
anestesis estetica di emozioni di
riflessioni
dunque un segno iconico non rinvia al
Desiderio ma ad uno sguardo necessario
sulla realtà
il segno iconico è utilizzato pochissimo
nella comunicazione perché esprimere
troppa realtà per chi guarda è
insostenibile
per restare alla questione della
montagna Non so se faccio un breve
filmato sulla fatica che fanno gli
studenti
secondari di Borga per raggiungere la
città a causa della carenza di mezzi
pubblici e faccio ascoltare che si
lamentano che si incazzano che avrebbero
voglia di alzarsi anche loro alle 7 di
mattina invece che alle 5
sicuramente mostro qualcosa di iconico
che ha a che fare con la realtà ma
sicuramente che non ha a che fare col
desiderio
e che tuttavia non fa parte del campo
del visibile
Dunque qual è il nostro problema Dal mio
punto di vista il nostro problema è che
il campo del visibile e il campo della
politica è popolato generalmente da
segni simbolici
che la nostra mente è popolata da un
patrimonio di simboli con cui leggiamo
interpretiamo costruiamo la realtà che
sono del tutto intenzionati da altri
che quando pensiamo Dunque il nuovo
trapassato e futuro lo pensiamo
attraverso questi simboli
e i simboli sono intenzionati da un
desiderio che è già posto in essi che
non è il nostro desiderio ma il
desiderio di qualcun altro
Ad esempio se ci chiedessimo quale
futuro per queste montagne per questi
luoghi per la Lessinia magari qualcuno
potrebbe essere tentato di ripensare a
quelle immagini che ha visto di Cortina
e di chiedersi se si può fare di Bolca
una piccola Cortina
Ma facendo questo non sarebbe Dal mio
punto di vista ovviamente da quello che
vi sto proponendo né critico né creativo
né tanto meno politico
perché non farebbe che aumentare
ulteriormente l'ideologia
andiamo alla terza parte
Che cos'è un segno iconico di se stesso
secondo Pier Paolo Pasolini
Pasolini afferma che un segno iconico di
se stesso è qualcosa che fa parte del
campo del non visibile
è un'immagine in cui chi guarda apprezza
direttamente la presenza violenta
singolare e fisica di ciò che è filmato
in uno dei più famosi film di Pasolini
noi vediamo
la merda filmata in presa diretta e
quindi abbiamo in qualche modo questa
questo tipo di disegno iconico
è un'immagine che mostra la realtà di
ciò che è dimenticato escluso o negato
proibito dal campo del visibile è
un'immagine che racconta questa realtà
attraverso la dettagliata
singolarità fisica sessuale carnale
Vitale originale
che non può essere espressa nel
simbolico perché sarebbe rifiutata dai
nostri occhi
dunque un segno iconico di se stesso
porta sullo schermo e sullo schermo
delle nostre menti e sullo schermo delle
nostre
anestesis delle nostre percezioni
qualcosa che è uno shock
qualcosa di scioccante per chi guarda
che non è più non è ancora o non lo è
stato mai abituato a vedere
in questo senso il segno iconico è un
atto politico che documenta qualcosa del
campo del non visibile
allora Che cosa significa che nella
nostra prossima idea ragionamento su
Bolca o sulla Lessinia mostriamo
solamente la fatica il disagio La
solitudine della vita di montagna
mostriamo solamente il fatto che gli
studenti devono alzarsi alle 5 di
mattina se vivono qui
non proprio Pasolini ci offre una strada
ed è quello che vado ad elencare
concludendo
Pasolini afferma che un segno iconico di
se stesso per essere accettato non deve
solo scioccare chi guarda ma al
contrario deve incontrare la simpatia il
piacere di chi guarda che cosa significa
Ecco a mio giudizio significa che la
soluzione per Pasolini è che bisogna
elevare quel segno iconico a livello
della Bellezza a livello della poesia a
livello dell'arte
che se vogliamo pensare qualcosa di
nuovo c'è bisogno di trovare una
connessione diretta tra la dimensione
politica dello shock del segno iconico e
la dimensione estetica del piacere della
simpatia
dell'empatia dell'amore
questa dimensione estetica
permette a chi pensa di pensare a chi
guarda di guardare e alla realtà di ciò
che era fuori dal campo del visibile di
potersi mostrare di conseguenza vorrei
dedurre tre
prospettive su cui ovviamente discutere
insieme attraverso quella che chiamo una
pedagogia delle immagini
e proprio rispetto al tema della
montagna primo
costruire un'immagine nuova della
montagna tra passato e futuro che tenga
insieme passato in futuro significa
avere il coraggio e può che
fenomenologica di prenderci il tempo di
sospendere i segni simbolici con cui
guardiamo la nostra montagna e di
cercare ciò che dice di iconico di reale
di vivo di originale nel nostro mondo
locale
secondo guardare la montagna come segno
iconico come qualcosa di originale vivo
reale
significa valorizzare ciò che è al di
fuori del campo del visibile ciò che è
al di fuori del campo del simbolico ciò
che può presentare una singolarità una
originalità
terzo lo sforzo più grande è quello di
elevare questa singola area originalità
alla bellezza
pensandola e mostrandola come un luogo
di amore e di piacere
è solo questo amore che io ad esempio
ritrovo in questo incontro in questo
incontro in questa idea di incontro è
solo questo amore questo piacere questa
bellezza per la nostra originalità che
ci permette di valorizzare e di
trasformare in immagini e che ci
permette di pensare qualcosa di nuovo
un incontro che io considero politico
perché non può solo cambiare la
percezione di chi vive in montagna ma di
chi sperimenta la montagna come turista
come
nomade Come come come
camminatore eccetera eccetera bene su
questo vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]